This brings us to the topic of creativity. We humans are naturally very
creative, and I'm not talking just about an Einstein or a Mozart. You and
I are very creative on an every day basis. You and
I constantly deal with our problems. And with dealing with our problems,
we don't just give up, we address them and most of the time fairly successfully.
Now the goal of knowledge-based AI is to create AI agents that can think and
act like humans. So shouldn't we also create knowledge-based AI agents that
are creative? But in order to answer this, we have to define what is creativity.
In lesson one, we saw how hard it was to define intelligence.
Defining creativity is no less hard. But we will give it a try anyway.